RIGHT KNOW AND SOUTH DAKOTA
GOVERNOR AND RISING STAR, KRISTI
NOEM.
BUT FIRST, THE PRESIDENT KNOWS
THE DEMOCRATS ARE TAKING ON
POLITICAL WATER AFTER FOR MONTHS
EXCUSING THESE RIOTOUS EVENTS.
THEY COLD THEM PROTESTS FOR THE
LONGEST PERIOD OF TIME.
THEY WENT INTO MASSIVE LOOTING
THAT DID ENORMOUS DESTRUCTION.
HE TOOK THEIR PATHETIC AND
ATTEMPT TO TAKE THE SHIFT TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HE TOOK THAT
ON TONIGHT.
>> IN THE STRONGEST POSSIBLE
TERPS, THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
CONDEMNS THE RIOTING, THE
LOOTING, ARSON AND VIOLENCE
WE’VE SEEN IN DEMOCRAT RUN
CITIES
CITIES LIKE KENOSHA AND
MINNEAPOLIS.
THEY NEVER MENTIONED ALL THE
RIOTING IN THEIR CONVENTION.
NOW THEY’RE STARTING TO MENTION
IT BECAUSE THEIR POLL NUMBERS
ARE GOING DOWN LIKE A ROCK IN
WATER.
>> JOE BIDEN AND HIS VICE
PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS CAME OUT
TODAY AND SUDDENLY STARTED
CONDEMNING THE VIOLENCE.
WELL, WHERE WERE THEY LAST WEEK?
THEY HAD AN ENTIRE CONVENTION
LAST WEEK.
THEY DIDN’T MENTION THE VIOLENCE
ONCE.
BLANDLY REFERRED TO PROTESTS AND
THE COURAGEOUS PROTESTS.
THE ATTEMPT TO LAY THE
DESTRUCTION IN THOSE CITIES AT
THE FEET OF DONALD TRUMP, HE
WASN’T GOING TO STAND FOR THAT
AT ALL.
>> LOOK, IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT,
DONALD TRUMP SAYING YOU’RE NOT
GO DOING BE SAFE IN JOE BIDEN’S
AMERICA, ALL THE VIDEO BEING
PLAYED IS BEING PLAYED IN DONALD
TRUMP’S AMERICA.
THESE GUYS ARE ROOTING FOR VIAL
LENTZ.
THAT’S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
>> YOU THINK THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES IS ROOTING FOR
THE VIOLENCE BECAUSE HE THINKS
IT HELPS HIM POLITICALLY?
>> I THINK HE VIEWS IT AS A
POLITICAL BENEFIT.
>> MAYORS AND GOVERNORS FROM
MINNESOTA, WISCONSIN, OREGON,
DENIED THE PRESIDENT’S ATTEMPT
TO BRING CALM TO THE STREETS.
THEY REJECTED IT ALL TOGETHER.
SO ARE THESE THE LEADERS THAT WE
WANT TO TURN THE KEYS OF THE
COUNTRY OVER TO?
THEY ALL VOTE FOR BIDEN.
THE ONES THAT ENGAGE IN THIS
DISGUSTING POLITICAL
CALCULATION.
SO THEY’RE PUTTING PARTISAN
INTERESTING ABOVE THE SAFETY OF
OUR PEOPLE?
TRUMP DOESN’T NEED POLITICAL
WINS TO PUSH HIM IN THE RIGHT
POSITION.
HE’S ALWAYS BEEN THERE.
>> YOUR VOTE WILL DECIDE IS
WHETHER WE PROTECT LAW-ABIDING
AMERICANS OR WHETHER WE GIVE
FREE REIGN TO VIOLENT ANARCHISTS
AND AGITATORS AND CRIMINALS THAT
THREATEN OUR CITIZENS.
>> TO DRIVE THAT POINT HOME, THE
PRESIDENT ASKED AN IMPORTANT
QUESTION TONIGHT.
WATCH.
>> AT THE DEMOCRAT NATIONAL
CONVENTION, JOE BIDEN AND HIS
PARTY REPEATEDLY ASSAILED
AMERICA AS A LAND OF RACIAL
ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL INJUSTICE.
SO TONIGHT I ASK YOU A SIMPLE
QUESTION.
HOW CAN THE DEMOCRAT PARTY ASK
TO LEAD OUR COUNTRY WHEN THEY
SPEND SO MUCH TIME TEARING DOWN
OUR COUNTRY.
>> THE ANSWER IS THEY CAN’T AND
THEY SHOULDN’T.
THE LEFT IS OBSESSED WITH POWER
AND AS THE PRESIDENT SAID
TONIGHT, THEY’LL TRY TO GET IT
BACK BY ANY MEANS NECESSARY.
UNLIKE PRESIDENT TRUMP WHO PUTS
THE PEOPLE’S INTEREST FIRST,
THEY PUT THEIR POLITICAL
INTERESTS FIRST AND THIS IS WHY
THEY WANT TO TRY TO TAKE THE
REINS OF POWER FROM HIM.
>> FROM THE MOMENT I LEFT MY
FORMER LIFE BEHIND AND IT WAS A
GOOD LIFE, I HAVE DONE NOTHING
BUT FIGHT FOR YOU.
I DID WHAT OUR POLITICAL
ESTABLISHMENT NEVER EXPECTED AND
COULD NEVER FORGIVE BREAKING THE
CARDINAL RULE OF WASHINGTON
POLITICS.
I KEPT MY PROMISE.
>> AMERICA IS A BETTER COUNTRY